Right now, somewhere out there,
an educator is delivering
a mind-altering lesson to their class.
I want to engage your brains in this.
Chris Anderson: I tried to get
my head around how vast our Earth is.
Logan Smalley: The lesson only reaches
the students in that room.
What would happen if we captured it?
It's a toothed wheel.
LS: What if pro animators
and visualization artists
could bring that lesson to life?
CA: It's a common object
that literally fits one million Earths.
It's got a bunch of notches
and a bunch of teeth.
This was Fizeau's solution --
LS: When that lesson lands,
curiosity is ignited.
CA: It seems impossibly big.
AS: Something interesting happens.
CA: In the great scheme
of things, it's a pinprick.
AS: A door closes on the light beam
that's coming back to his eye.
LS: Then that group of students
is one thought closer
to being what every teacher
hopes their students will become:
a lifelong learner.
AS: Based on the distance
between the two stations --
CA: The quest for knowledge
and understanding never gets dull.
AS: He calculates the speed of light
to within two percent of its actual value.
CA: The more you know,
the more amazing the world seems.
That's the central mission of TED-Ed:
to capture and to amplify
the voice of the world's
greatest teachers.
He does this in 1849.
CA: It's the crazy possibilities,
the unanswered questions,
that pull us forward.
So stay curious.
[TED-Ed: Lessons Worth Sharing]